بدأ جاك دريسكول يلاحظ
مشاكل في الذاكرة وسرعان ما علم أنه مصاب بمرض
الزهايمر، لقد أعطوني بعض الاختبارات
وقالوا
حسنًا، ستجريها بناءً
على الاختبار الذي تمكن دريسكول من إعداد
عائلته لما يمكن أن يتوقعوه، لقد
تحدثت مع زوجتي  وتحدثت مع
أطفالي وأخبرتهم أنه ربما في
المستقبل لن أعود
كما كنت عندما كنت أجري اختبار مرض الزهايمر. قد
يصبح الأمر أسهل كثيرًا قريبًا، حيث أظهرت دراسة جديدة
أن اختبار دم بسيط يسمى
ألباث يمكن أن يحدد مرض الزهايمر  لدى
الأشخاص قبل أن تبدأ الأعراض في الظهور،
قد يحدث هذا ثورة في تشخيص
مرض الزهايمر، واختبار الدم هذا
سيجعل من السهل والسريع
تشخيص هذه الحالة.
المؤشر النموذجي لمرض الزهايمر في الدماغ هو
تراكم البروتينات التي تسمى بيتا
أمالو وتاو حتى الآن.  كانت الطريقة التي
بحث بها الأطباء عن هذه البروتينات هي استخدام
فحوصات الدماغ أو بزل العمود الفقري، لكن لا
يمكن لأي شخص إجراء هذه الاختبارات، فحص PET،
SCS باهظ الثمن، لديهم إشعاع
بآلاف الدولارات، بزل العمود الفقري، هل
تعلم أنها تدخلية وتعلم أنها
تكلف الكثير من المال أيضًا  اختبار دم بسيط
يمكن أن يضفي طابعًا ديمقراطيًا على رعاية الأشخاص
ويحدد حقًا ما إذا كان الشخص معرضًا لخطر الإصابة
بالخرف قبل أن تبدأ الأعراض.
تظهر الدراسة الجديدة أن اختبار الدم هذا
يقارن بشكل جيد من حيث الدقة مع
فحوصات الدماغ والبزل الشوكي ليكون قادرًا على
اكتشاف وربما التنبؤ بمن لديه  مرض
الزهايمر حتى عندما يبدو الشخص
كأفراد عاديين يصابون
بمرض الزهايمر، فإنه يصاب
بالتغيرات المرضية في الدماغ لمدة تصل إلى
20 عامًا قبل أن تظهر الأعراض،
لذلك باستخدام هذا الاختبار يمكننا بالفعل رؤية
تلك التغيرات المرضية في الدم
أه، نعم أنت  قد يكونون قادرين على التقاط
هذا جيدًا قبل ظهور
الأعراض بأنفسهم وفقًا
لجمعية الزهايمر. يعيش أكثر من 6
ملايين شخص في الولايات المتحدة مع
الخرف الناجم عن مرض الزهايمر ومن
المتوقع أن يتضاعف عدد الأشخاص المتأثرين
في الولايات المتحدة في العامين المقبلين.
عقود من الزمن بينما لا يوجد حتى الآن علاج لمرض
الزهايمر عندما يكون الشخص لا يزال في
المرحلة الأولى، يطلق عليه
مرحلة الضعف الإدراكي المعتدل، لدينا الآن
العديد من الأدوية المعتمدة من إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية والتي
ثبت أن لها بعض
التأثيرات المعدلة للمرض أو إبطاء المرض
مما يجعل الكشف المبكر عن طريق
اختبار الدم هذا أكثر أهمية
يقدم جاك دريسكول هذه النصيحة لأي شخص تكون
نتيجة اختباره إيجابية، وأود أن أشجعه على
إبقاء حياته سعيدة قدر الإمكان.
وقالت جمعية الزهايمر لشبكة CNN إنها
تعتقد أن هذا العمل مشجع للغاية،
لكن المتحدث باسم الجمعية
أكد لنا ذلك  في الوقت الحالي، اختبار الدم هذا
مخصص للاستخدام في الأبحاث فقط
ولم تتم الموافقة عليه بعد من قبل إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية، وحذر
المتحدث من أن هناك
حاجة إلى مزيد من الاختبارات للمنتج
على ما أسماه
مجموعات سكانية متنوعة وممثلة. بريان تود
سي إن إن
واشنطن